ballet is supposed to be beautiful I'm
gonna make it look so a great I'm just
gonna be like holding on for dear life
I've been doing pole dance now for about
ten years you some crossfit and some
running and some spinning and sometimes
sometimes some yoga but mostly crossfit
you first started dating and we go
boxing like three times a week six
months into that I found Bar Method and
Pilates and I became addicted to that
more than the pole tricks like people
see the pole tricks and are like oh my
god I'm not strong enough to do that or
I'm not sexy enough it teaches you more
about yourself it teaches you how to use
your body and people learn that the
impossible is possible it's fun because
it's not just like you're working out to
work out you're working out because you
want to like it better at pull-ups you
like it better at push-ups it's dance so
like your bodyweight is what challenges
you and holds you back and you have more
body weight oh god now I'm really
thinking about it and I am so scared
I've never taken the class but um the TA
is going down I do this with the baby a
lot I want to say five days a week but I
don't but it's really just like what
excited I'm not I'm truly terrified all
right let's do it
that's God hi my name is Lucy and I am a
CrossFit coach at CrossFit mindset and
today I am taking Kate and Jared through
a CrossFit workout so I know Kate has a
good engine and that she'll push through
the workout pretty quickly
I've only seen Jared in the last three
and a half four years that I've known
him to work out one time we're at health
LA in Los Angeles and today I'm going to
be teaching an amazing pole class it's a
great workout for anybody no matter if
you're a man or a woman so guys out
there give it a try
it's Oh long as you are prepared for to
be out of your comfort zone
- great okay cool cool laughs okay let's
do it starts with dream easy lift right
into the height of your hips lift lift
so one thing at a time is gonna come up
while your toes down towards the floor
with you today so first go ahead and
give me 30 jumping jacks all right and
right up mm all right up once you your
knee and then leave for your front leg
now I'm gonna get to round forward those
all right head to your bar front squat
rest your hands either somewhere on your
leg or you can hold on to the bar
wherever it feels okay for your stretch
raise your rooms I are
that you're keeping your
and put your palm for this tonight
you're really good so the first one
we're going to learn is called a Firefly
beginner move since you're a beginner
okay 1 2 3 turn and hook your left foot
and then you're going to push off right
leg in the back bring it up nice and
sexy wait a minute is my hand supposed
to be slippery or something yeah yeah
bring your chest up so your shoulders
are right above your hips good do it
eight more times in your last thing
press down squeeze in one down squeeze
two down squeeze three down in four
there's that shake squeeze in five keep
it down
in six down seven James goes eh hold
that next one low and squeeze just
squeeze in to finish it'll squeeze on
the mat let it burn you guys are almost
there
here's what happened come on back push
press
[Music]
Jarrid adjust your feet to be a little
closer underneath your hips
1 2 3 turn to hook the left foot right
leg goes and back
and then push that booty up oh yeah all
right take tars if that was pretty good
for the first one you can see my to make
it look so easy today nope so close
you're so close kill me so I'm giving
him a slightly easier band to work with
for his next couple rounds go okay open
the leg split drop it
keep going yes half the size oh my
gooood Damon Thanks then this knee
bending oh good okay bring it up to EXCI
bring f that right my hips hurry and my
sweaty to music and opening
I'm trying to party
[Music]
there's parcel bud too much this went
here your sideways that's Shane you're
doing you're doing squats while on the
ball of your feet that like George was
driving me crazy because like your
entire Phi is on fire he's going to see
what she does every day and I respect
their lies so when she says I'm tired
I'm gonna do nothing I think I might
believe in it you're supposed to suck
when you first start a guy sucked really
yeah I really did that's up you did the
hardest move was to twerking around Pope
uh you know I love Magic Mike and
biblical black magic I thought I can do
it no I had to take his weight down
because it was too heavy for the
movements just cuz he hasn't done it in
a long time you know feels pretty good
you know those endorphins yeah man I
think Jared did really super good
like he well he's good at like putting
his mind to something I just feel like
I'm gonna I'm going to do this Casey was
strong I didn't know how strong like
she's a super strong until she got that
baby and I'm excited hearts where you
feel like silly in the league other than
that I miss your review um ten out of
ten would do it yeah I I would um yeah
no because yeah I'm not coming in like
by myself like you do where's the bar
now like I would uh I would do it again
though no terrible huh okay does this
every morning I like six almost
[Music]